OUT HERE.
>> Neil: THANKS, CASEY.
TO A REPUBLICAN TEXAS
CONGRESSMAN WHO WONDERING HOW
THESE PEOPLE ARE ENDING UP IN
HIS DISTRICT AND NOBODY
EXPLAINS.
CONGRESSMAN, THANKS FOR TAKING
THE TIME.
WERE YOU GETTING ANY WORD ON
THIS?
>> NEIL, THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
THE REPORTING ON THIS CAN'T BE
OVERSTATED ENOUGH, THAT YOU GUYS
ARE GETTING THE WORD OUT.
NO, WE'RE NOT GETTING A
HEADS-UP.
WE GOT WORD FROM BORDER PATROL
THAT THERE COULD BE A
POSSIBILITY DHS IS BASICALLY
FORCING BORDER PATROL TO PLAN
FOR THESE TYPES OF EVENTS
BECAUSE THEY'RE COMPLETELY
OVERWHELMED.
WHEN I SAY FORCING, THEY HAVE NO
OTHER OPTION.
LET'S KEEP IN MIND THAT 2.9
MILLION ENCOUNTERS HAVE
HAPPENED.
800,000 GOT-AWAYS.
THERE'S A HUGE COST TO OUR
COUNTRY.
YES ECONOMIC AND I CAN GET INTO
THAT BUT ALSO NATIONAL SECURITY.
LET'S ALSO REMEMBER THAT FOR
9-11, IT ONLY TOOK A HANDFUL OF
PEOPLE TO PLANNED THAT.
SINCE BIDEN HAS BEEN IN OVER,
OVER 50 PEOPLE ON THE TEARIST
WATCH LIST HAVE BEEN FOUND.
WHAT ABOUT THE GOT-AWAYS.
>> Neil: HOW ARE THE MIGRANTS
PROCESSED AND WHERE DO THEY GO?
EXPLAIN THE PROCESS.
>> THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO KNOW
FROM SECRETARY MAYORKAS.
WHERE ARE THEY GOING TO LIVE AND
HOW ARE THEY GOING TO SUSTAIN
LIFE?
THOSE ARE THE QUESTIONS NOT
ANSWERED BY DHS.
WE HAVE NOT RECEIVED A SUPPLY.
QUITE FRANKLY, THE SYSTEM IS
OVERWHELMED.
THE TOWNS THEY'RE GOING TO ARE
THE WHOLE SYSTEM WHETHER IT'S ON
THE GOVERNMENT OR THE DHS SIDE
OR NGO SIDE IS OVERWHELMED.
2.99 MILLION ENCOUNTERS SINCE
BIDEN TOOK OFFICE.
>> Neil: SO FINALLY, I'D LIKE TO
GET A GAUGE.
THE ADMINISTRATION WILL SEND
THEM BEYOND THE BORDER TO POINTS
NORTH IN TEXAS.
I GET THAT.
THEY DON'T SHARE THE GOVERNOR'S
DEAL WITH ANY OF THE POINTS FOR
FURTHER NORTH THAN JUST TEXAS SO
WASHINGTON D.C., DELAWARE, SOME
OF THESE OTHER POINTS.
DO YOU KNOW IF THAT COULD
CHANGE?
>> THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND FROM THE SECRETARY.
YOU KNOW, WHERE IS HE CHOOSING
TO SEND THESE.
WHAT CITIES ARE BEING
CONSIDERED.
OBVIOUSLY WHEN WE HAD THE
INITIAL INDICATION THAT THIS
COULD HAPPEN IN MY DISTRICT, WE
WERE VERY CONCERNED.
YOU KNOW, WE SAY THAT EVERY
STATE AND EVERY CITY IS A BORDER
STATE AND A BORDER CITY.
THE COST TO AMERICANS IS
INCOMPARABLE.
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND WHEN THEIR
PLAN IS.
THIS IS A SYMPTOM.
THE FACT THAT BORDER PATROL
AGENTS THAT ARE EVEN HAVING TO
THINK ABOUT THIS IS RIDICULOUS.
THEY NEED TO BE THINKING ABOUT
THE NATIONAL SECURITY MISSION
AND MAKING SURE THAT ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE SAFE.
THE FENTANYL THAT IS POURED IN,
THE MOUND OF CRIME, DRUGS,
TRAFFICKING.
IT'S ENORMOUS.
WE NEED TO GET BACK TO THE RULE
OF LAW.
WE DON'T NEED NEW LAWS.
WE NEED THE PRESIDENT TO ENFOR